hi my name is Sebastian Maniscalco and I
feel
honored about being Conan O'Brien that's
very sweet that's very nice of you to
say that although listen
I know we've we've met uh you've done
the show many times yeah but we haven't
really
had a relationship outside the show it's
not like I'm calling you going what are
you doing Friday night we're having some
wine you want to come by I just don't
know I love it if you had done that I
would love to have
but you didn't do it for me either you
know well that's not going to happen
Sebastian There are rules you know I was
the host of the show and so no matter
you've become huge you're massive you're
as as big a comedy Star as I can imagine
but still you know because I was the
host of those shows I had to have a wall
up okay you understand I do understand
but but
my question is being a host of a show
like that right and you've got a lot of
people coming through the door day in
Day Out
have you made friendships over the years
with a lot of your guests yes I have
okay and I have with a a pretty actually
a pretty good number you just click with
people and
um and one of the things it takes is
just bumping into them someplace else
that's usually what has to happen is you
bump into them someplace else so I'm
sure if I bumped into you
and we were hanging out
uh you would have thought this is the
greatest guy I ever met in my
life
and then you would have sent them to the
waiter you know more wine over here and
I said let me get it Sebastian this is
on me and you've been like I love this
guy and then the next thing I'd be at
your house yeah that would have happened
but we never bumped into each other okay
because you were very careful not to
bump into me yeah I didn't uh I didn't I
didn't go out much when I was around no
you were always out on the town and the
minute you read Conan O'Brien's in town
you would lay low yeah you would lay low
until I passed through no I'm very happy
for you you know you uh it's funny I was
trying to think of what there's you're
very funny comic you are an amazingly
successful comedian and you've done
really well as an actor and I was trying
to think
what is it that Sebastian does that
always made me laugh whenever you would
come on the show
and
I realized today it was your amazement
you do amazement better than most
comedians I know you're totally amazed
by how screwed up or up something
is yeah and that is a big part of your
personality and you stretch it out your
physicality is really great but you have
this your personality like inflates when
you're saying what's going on with this
I don't understand and there are a lot
of comedians that do what's going on
with blank your amazement is you're the
Olivier of Amazement you really are you
know what I'm talking about yeah
now I'm constantly
shocked and amazed at you know whether
it be human behavior situations or what
have you I just have an exaggerated uh
way of looking at things it's been the
way I've kind of looked at life since I
was a kid so it's not like it's
something that I'm putting on for I mean
obviously I'm it's comedy so you have to
exaggerate a little bit but the the the
seed of it is coming from complete awe
and shock of what I'm seeing so uh yeah
that tends to be kind of the uh the core
of uh of of the comedy but you know
what's great is you tie it in with your
um with your history
as an Italian American you know your
your dad I know we'll get to this
because it's a it's a huge part of your
movie
um and I cannot believe you got Robert
De Niro to play your dad I mean this is
this is most there are people out there
that say I want to make a movie about my
life I'll find someone to play my dad
you know and uh I don't even want to
know who I would be able to get oh
I know your wheels are turning it would
not be Robert De Niro Orville redenbach
but uh but I'm I'm really uh so so I
think that
you you do this very yes we all do that
we exaggerate we take who we are really
and then we turn up the knob to like 15
uh for for the comedic's sake but the
core of it is pure and what you do is it
it feels
it's a very Italian yeah attitude about
what the is this all about yeah
it's in the culture so the the
upbringing and and my father is a huge
part of my comedy just because you know
it came from Sicily he's uh when he was
15 years old and he brought a lot of
those old world values To America with
them and then in the upbringing those
kind of values were passed on to me and
uh yeah it's just I notice Italian
people I just did uh um a TV show and
the other actress on the TV show was
Italian and when Italians get together
it's almost like um we other people are
looking at us and it's like we speak
like dolphins they don't even know the
they don't even know the communication
like they're like no I I thought there
was going to be a fight that was going
to break out at any minute when you guys
were talking but it was you know we kind
of just know there's a familiar way how
we communicate with one another and then
when we start speaking outside of the of
the culture a lot of people tend to see
it and go oh oh this is a different kind
of take on life and and the take comes
from pretty much my dad yeah it was a
huge personality and uh has a lot to say
and um I don't know I just took what
basically what we were talking about at
the kitchen table as a kid and then made
a living out of it I have said uh for
many years that it all starts at the
kitchen table
um that's where it started for me was a
lot of brothers and sisters and Sunday
dinner that was the one constant was
Sunday dinner and then we'd be there and
you'd just try and see who could make
who could crack up the table the most
and that's where it starts I really
believe believe it's it's the same thing
but what's interesting to me about the
uh I think you've said that there's a
there's almost a negativity with an
Italian point of view that's built in is
that true constantly negative everything
is always
um bad nothing's ever good we can't talk
about it being good because if you talk
about being good something bad is going
to happen so that's uh it's just so sad
it's just it's just the way it is and uh
yeah it's like I now have trouble
enjoying
the fruits of my labor right I I don't
know if you guys have this problem but
like I'm at a point in my life where I
should really be extremely happy about
what's happening to me yeah yet there is
a you know part of me that is always
kind of looking for the next thing and
am I doing enough you know like am I
it's just I got a podcast is it good
enough I'm doing a TV show is it good
enough so it I I can't sit there and
relax right and I don't know if that's
just me or is that people who get to a
certain level in their career and feel
like they gotta maintain that level or
and you can't relax until I'm reading
this book called die with zero right
because I'm having an issue with uh
spending money
and the issue being you're spending too
much you're not spending it I don't know
what to spend like I like I didn't I
grew up working middle class right and
it was the money was a huge Topic in our
house and it was always safe save your
money because you don't know if your
tongue is gonna fall out and you can't
do this anymore right which does happen
I wouldn't worry about that one
particular thing
give yourself a break yeah
during covet you weren't worried at all
about covid you were worried
don't worry you're clear on covet my
tongue the tongue could go at any time
what yeah well I mean Coleman was a
great example it's like you save for a
rainy day right and the rainy day came
and I was still going hot you know like
I didn't even use the savings right I
was just trying to figure out how I
could make money and and and live off
whatever doing uh corporate zooms you
know that's what I was doing
I wasn't doing like stand up in my
living room but it would be like a uh a
moderator asking me questions and I
would be making the company laugh
and zoom I did like 38 of these things
okay let me just let me just put this in
context for our listeners who don't know
and many people are aware of your
massive success
you sold out four shows at Madison
Square Garden that's insane that's an
insane achievement that's you and a
microphone sold out Madison Square
Garden four of them how many of those
people were on Zoom though
half to be fair they put a lot of TV TV
screens TV screens look at me hi
everybody I'm 60. I don't know if you've
met me I think that works when I assume
it's a TV
I was picturing televisions with rabbit
ears and a zoom coming over the seats
the televisions are in this let's just
let it go but my point is Sebastian I'm
just wanting to put it in context for
people that you've had this insane this
isn't there are plenty of people in the
business that book a sitcom but they're
being careful with their money or this
or that you've had uh unprecedented
level of success that uh I can promise
you right now is not going anywhere you
have talent and ability and it's not
going anywhere and you have a devout
following
but it's fascinating to me that
you know when when it's stops for a
little bit you're thinking oh my God how
am I going to make the rent and to me
that is that is this is a very common
situation and I do think that it may not
be a coincidence that your dad
immigrated here uh because I mean
famously Bob Hope who you know biggest
comedian maybe of the 20th century
um he came from he emigrated
from Wales as a kid and was incredibly
poor growing up and tried to make it as
a boxer and his family were like stone
masons I mean he had nothing and he
scrounged and scratched and scratched
and finally made it and then bought up
all the Orange Groves in California when
he started making money and be by the
time he's in his 90s
he's I think the richest
Entertainer in the United States of
America is just incredibly wealthy man
and I know for a fact that he would go
into the valley
um and with coupons for Carl's Jr to me
it's that doesn't go away yeah you
know when you have and although
you didn't experience that maybe
firsthand you inherit it from your dad
and it's very powerful yeah so I mean to
me it makes it makes sense that you're
that way yeah but my whole challenge now
is I got like one one foot living in
that world and I got a one foot living
in the world I'm in right now and I'm
trying to like
you know just just be a little bit more
relaxed when it comes to you know
enjoying my success I guess that's
that's the struggle I'm having at this
current point right in my life it's a
good problem yeah it's a good problem
but I know what you mean I know what
you're I I know what you're talking
about
um and I recommend medication
a lot of it and all kinds don't even
just get it from other people I'm not
don't even see a psychopharmacologist I
think just get it random pills from
other people and try them out okay
terrible advice